We are now ready for
the climatic big theorem of this lesson.
The Max-Flow Min-Cut Theorem.
It's states that
the following are equivalent,
f is a maximum flow in a flow network G.
The residual graph Gf
has no augmenting paths.
And there exists an s-t cut (A,B) such
that the value of the flow is equal to
the value of the cut.
This is the realization of
the strategy outlined earlier
where we're going to introduce
the notion of a cut,
show that it served as an upper
bound on the flow, and
then show that Ford-Fulkerson produced
a flow with the same value as a cut.
So as an immediate corollary,
we have then that the Ford-Fulkerson
approach returns a maximum flow.
Let's see a proof of the theorem.
We start by showing that if
f is a maximum flow in G,
then the residual graph
has no augmenting paths.
Well, suppose not.
And let f' be an augmenting flow.
Then, we can augment f by f', and
as we've argued this will be a flow.
And the value of the flow will be
the sum of the values of the individual
flows, which must be strictly
greater than the value of f.
But we assumed it was a maximum,
so that creates a contradiction.
Next, we show that the fact that the
residual network has no augmenting path
implies that there is a s-t cut
who's capacity is the same
as the value of the flow.
This is the real heart of the theorem.
We let A be the set of
vertices we can reach from S.
In the residual graph Gf and
we let B be the complement to that.